[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
jeudi 11 octobre
depuis le 6 octobre c'est la fête de la
science à saint quentin en yvelines
de nombreux ateliers expositions sont
proposées dans toute l'agglomération
pour aborder la science de façon ludique
ce week-end un village des sciences se
tiendra à la commanderie
armelle au brier sera avec nous pour
nous en parler de la course et du vélo à
plaisir samedi
amateurs et semi professionnels sont
invités à composer des duos pour un
parcours tout terrain et une arrivée au
parc du château de plaisir et enfin
mesure apparaît découvrir le grand front
de victor hugo l'exposition hugo à la
lune présente 180 caricature du célèbre
auteur plus bédié au 19e siècle
reportage en fin de magazine depuis le 6
octobre et jusqu'au bord c'est la fête
de la science ateliers conférences
spectacles saint quentin en yvelines
propose de nombreuses animations pour
l'occasion parmi elles l'exposition
corps mouvement et innovation à la
commanderie
mélanie peau caissière en doute pour
nous la faire découvrir pour la fête de
la science la commanderie a décidé de
nous parler du corps sous toutes ses
coutures
l'exposition réalisée par l'atelier des
sciences de saint quentin en yvelines
vous propose d'être acteur d exploration
du corps humain il y a une grande
tablette tactile qui s'appelle le profit
le scope qui propose un dialogue avec
une anthropologue un dialogue virtuel
avec une anthropologue et qui vous
permet de constituer le profil
biologique d'un squelette il y a
également une exploration à la loupe du
corps humain pour découvrir des
anecdotes sur le corps humain
on propose également une exploration
mathématiques où le public est invité à
se mesurer
sous toutes ses coutures et pourquoi pas
étudier la divine proportions une
exploration microscopique avec un
microscope
en réalité virtuelle la deuxième partie
n'est pas de tout repos et permet de
découvrir le mouvement
quant à la troisième elle nous plonge
dans le futur il nous parle innovations
dans le domaine de la mobilité et de la
motricité avec par exemple la
présentation d'une maquette
d'exosquelette qu'on n'est pas juste
pour les enfants mais les enfants
apprécient cette exposition et les
adultes aussi on a justement essayer
d'apporter à la fois des connaissances
pour les adultes est aussi une
découverte plus ludique pour les enfants
l'exposition est proposée à la
commanderie dès l'âge de 6 ans jusqu'au
25 novembre est donc une exposition pour
laquelle on s'implique qui ont même des
expériences car la fête de la science
est beaucoup de découvertes en est dans
un esprit très pédagogique avec nous
armelle ouvriers on joue alors vous êtes
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines notamment en
charge de la culture
donc on l'a vu samedi 6 octobre il y
avait la nuit blanche avec l'ouverture
de cette exposition
comment ça s'est passé c'est un bon
lancement très bien très bon très bon
lancement
on a eu donc on a fait cette exposition
sur l'exploration du corps humain et moi
je suis resté de 8 heures à 22 heures il
y avait toujours du monde au moins 25 ou
30 personnes dans la salle des cette
position et à partir de ce moment là on
en a profité aussi pour faire découvrir
de la photographie et les nouveautés sur
la photographie de chacun pouvait créer
sa planète dans l'univers et il y avait
aussi un spectacle de danse une première
une première nuit blanche qui s'est
terminée un peu tôt à minuit mais
réussit et qui a attiré pour une
première alors ça a commencé avec la
nuit blanche toute toute la semaine on
avait des activités un peu répartis en
aura d'autres la semaine prochaine
on peut dire que il ya vraiment une
volonté de faire découvrir la science
est un large public et lui faire
découvrir la science un large public
depuis parce que sur le territoire de
saint quentin c'est aussi l'image de 50
ha parce qu'en fait on est dans le
domaine de l'industrie
on est dans le domaine de l'innovation
et c'est ce que saint-quentin veut veut
supporter donc tout va ensemble
et effectivement on va faire la semaine
la fête de la science depuis le 6
octobre jusqu'au 20 octobre l'exposition
sur le coeur humain durera après c'est à
dire que pendant les vacances d'automne
elle sera ouverte et donc tout le monde
pourra participer
après on aura le village des sciences
j'allais revenir là ce week end le
village des sciences donc c'est un bon
moment phare de cette fête des sciences
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir y faire à ce
village des sciences alors on va y faire
des activités scientifiques donc on va
rencontrer des associations où toute
façon ça sera toujours interactif et
c'est des petites séquences de 2,15
minutes 20 minutes ou une demi heure
il ya deux grands thèmes donc il ya la
démarche scientifique ou là on va aussi
bien vous parlez des abeilles que des
pierres volcaniques que de galilée là la
base de la science
et puis tourner vers les nouvelles
technologies il y aura aussi des
ateliers et des explications sur la
robotique et les nouvelles technologies
alors ils ont gagné
vu en fait on va proposer de découvrir
de développer une nouvelle théorie il a
vérifié en fait ça avec ma part vraiment
sur la démarche scientifique mais voilà
ces taxes est un c'est un échange en
fait tous et des expériences et
effectivement pour faire comprendre les
choses mais c'est aussi bien pour les
jeunes ou les où les enfants que pour
les adultes cb comment s'est tourné vers
eux tout le monde
alors ces différentes propositions il
faudra regarder le programme sur sur le
site de la commanderie mais ça lieu le
vendredi le samedi et le dimanche
certains ont lieu le vendredi et le
samedi le vendredi c'est plus et les
élèves scolaires le vendredi et le
samedi et d'autres ont lieu le vendredi
le samedi le dimanche ou le samedi et le
dimanche il y aura trente stands au
total ou des associations des
laboratoires des sociétés dont on sent
qu'il ya un enthousiasme qui a fédéré
vous attendez du monde
oui alors en plus on veut rendre sa
convivial donc il y aura un café
éphémère le samedi et le dimanche
donc entre deux activités il y aura
possibilité d'écouter de la musique de
pouvoir rejouer sport dont on a parlé du
côté démarche scientifique
on peut aussi rencontrer des robots
parce que c'est un quentin en yvelines
c'est un peu l'innovation exactement
celle et oui c'est enfin tout ce qui est
tourné autour des nouvelles technologies
il a fait donc la robotique depuis par
exemple un des thèmes c'est pourquoi des
satellites d'observation au tourne
autour de la terre comme en fait de la
fabrication numérique les robots dans
l'est dans les usines enfin pour aider à
la fabrication du sport et des maths
voilà parce qu'en fait la robotique qui
s'appuie sur les mathématiques et tout
ça d'un bon niveau c'est pas beatty
fiancée d'un bon niveau mais c'est pour
expliquer toutes ces évolutions du mode
de vie et du monde attendent donc ce
sera la sortie annuelle ce week-end et
pendant l'épreuve jusqu'au 20 octobre
avec des nombreux ateliers dans toute
l'agglomération
merci à mme manouvrier d'être venu sur
place
au village des sciences et samedi et
dimanche de 14h à 18h à la commanderie à
elancourt vous pouvez retrouver le
programme complet sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran et pour se
détendre après toutes ces expériences
scientifiques place à l'humour pourrir
en musique le chanteur oldelaf se
produit à l'espace albert camus à
maurepas
il se fait connaître par le grand public
avec son titre la tristitude et se
déplace aujourd'hui dans toute la france
pour interpréter son septième album
goliath
vendredi 2 octobre à 20h30 manu payet
joue emmanuel son dernier one man show
samedi 13 octobre à 20h30 cela se passe
à la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux
il reviendra en février au prix smile en
cours l'espace coluche de plaisir
accueille le duo fou de vivement
dimanche prochain
ben arnaud tsamère sont enfin sur scène
dans un espace dans un spectacle écrit à
quatre mains
il reste se déplacer samedi 13 octobre à
20h30
la quatrième édition du run and bike de
plaisir se déroulera samedi 13 octobre
l'occasion de tester son esprit d équipe
un vélo pour un binôme qui courait
pédales en alternance des courses des 2
km pour les enfants et de 8 et 15 km
pour les plus courageux
le tout dans le joli cadre du parc du
château de plaisir les premiers départs
se font à 9h30 pour les retardataires
qui se décideraient au dernier moment de
l'inscription est possible sur place une
heure avant le départ
pensez à vous munir d'un certificat
médical joséphine coleman sperger au
micro de mélanie poquet nous avons
depuis plusieurs années un temps
toujours avec nous et je pense que c'est
un rendez vous maintenant que les
plaisirs aux attendes on a 450
participants donc tous ces participants
là et bien entraînent avec eux les
familles qui viennent les voir puis
aussi des sportifs qui viennent
d'ailleurs pour les voir aussi on a la
chance d'avoir en centre ville
ce magnifique parc et ce château du
xviiie et que le sport et la culture et
le patrimoine font très bon ménage et
pour une course plus classique la 9e
édition du trail des sept hameaux a lieu
dimanche 14 octobre d une messe 18 km de
course et 400 m de dénivelé
essentiellement en sous bois dans le
parc régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse le départ est prévu pour 9h 30
à magny les hameaux
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
sont en finale
de d1 face aux huskies de rouen ils sont
menés deux matchs à 0 et devront tout
donner samedi pour revenir dans la
course à la coupe
le match aura lieu samedi à 15h pu
dimanche harms harms heures et 14 heures
en cas de victoire victor hugo comme on
le connaît peu l'auteur des misérables a
été l'un des personnages publics les
plus de caricatures et de son temps la
maison victor hugo hugo expose ses
dessins dans le 4e arrondissement de
paris jusqu'au 6 janvier
reportage de nicolas le hérissé de nos
confrères via grand paris avec son corps
disproportionnée son large front victor
hugo a été l'un des personnages publics
les plus caricaturer l'exposition hugo à
la une présente 180 caricatures publiées
entre 1830 et 1885 des dessins qui le
montre sous des traits qui le suivront
tout au long de sa vie au victor hugo
c'est principalement à partir des années
30 son grand front qu'on met en avant si
je puis dire qui est un signe
d'intelligence qui est le symbole de
l'écrivain et qui est un signe
d'ambition
par ailleurs mais ça c'est pas spécial à
hugo au 19e il ya toujours des dégoûts
de très grosses têtes et des tout petits
corps il est souvent associé également
un monument cela à partir de 1830 31 32
qui est la parution de notre dame de
paris et donc on leur présente souvent
avec la cathédrale
les tours de notre-dame en arrière-plan
ces dessins ont été réalisés par des
caricaturistes de tous bords politiques
publiés régulièrement une cette
profusion montre à quel point victor
hugo était omniprésent sur la scène
publique
ses engagements politiques et ses
nombreux textes lui ont valu des dessins
peu flatteur mais l'écrivain toujours
défendu la liberté de le représenter
victor hugo ne s'est jamais opposé à ce
qu'on caricature il n'a jamais protesté
contre un dessin même si le dessin était
féroce contre lui ni victor hugo a
toujours prôné la liberté de la presse
et il a toujours défendu la liberté
absolue de 2,2 d'écrire de lire et de
dessiner à partir des années 1860 et
caricatures le concernant sont plutôt
des caricatures dommage donc donc il
pouvait que bien les recevoir
deuxièmement depuis le début victor hugo
est favorable à la presse qu simplement
parce que ça lui permet accroît sa
notoriété il faudra attendre la fin de
sa vie pour que les caricaturistes porte
un regard bienveillant sur victor hugo
il sera alors croquer en poète antique
presque élevé aux statues de divinités
et avant de vous quitter un appel à
candidatures a regardé attentivement
pour les humoristes en devenir
bonjour j'ai des papiers je connais
l'encours ouais tu vas le prisme en
avril le rythme est lent est-ce que je
ne fais que ça je ris à gorge déployée
10 clos il manque encore des choses dont
je sens qu'il ya du potentiel
et ce qui est super c'est qu'aux prises
le questionnement on va faire pas
plateau d'humour on va les chercher des
humoristes un peu partout qui vaut venir
sur ce plateau ce délai
chocques les entend surtout rire les
gens ararat et ça ça sera le cap des
sons et oui on est dans le bio on est
dans lequel on est dans le circuit court
et même dans l'humour c'est pour ça
qu'on attend vos vidéos vos propositions
devant une petite vidéo d'une minute
2008 trois minutes max hockey attention
et ça avant le 17 octobre
vous nous auriez ces vidéos nous on
regarde et pourquoi pas participer le 4
décembre à ces puits une notre plateau
d'humour un peu de tous les deux notre
bébé tout cela en plus sera retransmis
sur tv 78 euros et c'est la fin de votre
situe à dire merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro
m
ouais
oh
[Musique]